Katrina:  那就把这个拿了
Katrina: Then let's take this one.
Tasha: 算了吧那把这个拿了吧
Tasha: Fine, let's take this one.
Katrina:  好谦让哈哈哈
Katrina: So considerate, haha.
Katrina:  还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Tasha: 我们还找
Tasha: We also found...
Tasha: 我们还买了个芋
Tasha: We also bought some taro.
Tasha: 魔芋魔芋魔芋啊
Tasha: Konjac, konjac, konjac!
Tasha: 你们有买魔芋吗
Tasha: Did you guys buy konjac?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Lucia: 我们没有吧
Lucia: I don't think so.
Katrina:  够了
Katrina: That's enough.
Tasha: 那就行那我把豆腐拿走
Tasha: Alright, then I'll take the tofu.
Katrina:  火锅调料要买蒜吗
Katrina: Do we need to buy garlic for the hotpot seasoning?
Alice: 哦蒜买了
Alice: Oh, I already bought garlic.
Alice: 哦蒜有这个
Alice: Oh, we have this garlic.
Jake:拍个照吧
Jake: Let's take a picture.
Alice:有这种蒜
Alice: We have this kind of garlic.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就这么草率
Katrina: Hahaha, so hasty.
Alice: 露出来了
Alice: It's showing.
Katrina:  非常的潦草啊
Katrina: So sloppy.
Shure:  我们少个人
Shure: We're missing someone.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is he?
Alice:他去放豆腐了
Alice: He's placing the tofu.
Jake:好等他回来
Jake: Okay, let's wait for him to come back.
Lucia: 哦这个是什么
Lucia: Oh, what's this?
Alice:板栗
Alice: Chestnut.
Lucia: 哎我没有见过这种板栗
Lucia: Oh, I've never seen this kind of chestnut.
Shure:  哎萝卜胡萝卜咸萝卜嫩芽子
Shure: Oh, radishes, carrots, salty radishes, and young sprouts.
Shure:  香椿好韭菜嘞
Shure: Smells good, leeks.
Lucia: 哈哈哈观察一下观察一下
Lucia: Hahaha, take a closer look.
Shure:  变异了是不是变异了
Alice:这还卧了个蛋呢
Alice: There's even an egg in here.
Jake: 咱重建一下
Jake: Let's rebuild it.
Jake: 让他重建一下
Jake: Let him rebuild it.
Shure:  香菜
Shure: Cilantro.
Shure:  青椒哎
Shure: Green pepper, hey.
Alice: 这还是个公的
Alice: This one's a male.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 公的哈哈哈
Lucia: A male, hahaha.
Lucia: 发现盲点
Lucia: Found a blind spot.
Jake:哈哈哈揣俩蛋
Jake: Hahaha, carrying two eggs.
Katrina: 来吧一起
Katrina: Come on, let's do it together.
Tasha: 这家店没有了
Tasha: This store doesn't have it.
Alice: 荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro.
Tasha: 这家店没有
Tasha: This store doesn't have it.
Tasha: 另一家店有
Tasha: The other store does.
Katrina:  有什么
Katrina: What do they have?
Alice: 在哪说
Alice: Where did you say?
Tasha: 说很近
Tasha: They said it's very close.
Tasha: 另外一家很近
Tasha: The other store is very close.
Alice: 他能调货吗
Alice: Can they transfer the goods?
Lucia: 我们刚才找到了保鲜膜
Lucia: We just found the plastic wrap.
Jake:拍拍拍个照拍个照拍个照吧
Jake: Let's take a photo, take a photo, take a photo.
Tasha: 他调不了
Tasha: He can't adjust it.
Katrina: 拍个照吧
Katrina: Let's take a photo.
Lucia: 他一起吗
Lucia: Is he joining?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 他是真的吗
Tasha: Is he real?
Alice: 假的
Alice: Fake.
Jake:来拍照了
Jake: Come on, let's take a photo.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好放回去
Jake: Okay, put it back.
Tasha: 为什么要跟一只鸡合照
Tasha: Why are we taking a photo with a chicken?
Lucia: 这是顺手的
Lucia: It's handy.
Katrina:  哈哈
Jake:因为看到了
Jake: Because we saw it.
Alice:这是下蛋公鸡
Alice: This is a laying rooster.
Shure: 下蛋公鸡
Shure: A laying rooster.
Shure:  公鸡下蛋
Shure: A rooster that lays eggs.
Shure: 公鸡中的战斗机
Shure: The fighter jet of roosters.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: Appears.
Shure:  行大家的表情一样的僵硬
Shure: Okay, everyone's expression is equally stiff.
Shure:  我就哈哈哈放心了
Shure: I feel relieved, haha.
Shure:  哈哈哈像
Shure: Haha, it looks like...
Jake:相对民众
Jake: Relative to the crowd.
Lucia: 这好像是个动图吧
Lucia: This looks like a GIF, right?
Lucia: 是动图吧
Lucia: Is it a GIF?
Lucia: 我跟你讲我们原来那个
Lucia: Let me tell you, we used to...
Shure:  是动图我们办公室拍照
Shure: It's a GIF. We took photos in our office.
Shure:  然后有一个是原来当过idol的那种
Shure: And there was someone who used to be an idol.
Shure:  嗯然后就
Shure: And then...
Shure:  他跟我们就感觉不是一个涂层的
Shure: He felt like he wasn't on the same layer as us.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Shure:  就人家那个表情管理和装造我靠
Shure: His expression management and styling, oh my god.
Tasha: 呃有个音效你去听一下
Tasha: Uh, there's a sound effect, you should listen to it.
Lucia: 没有音效是他模仿的
Lucia: No sound effect, he was mimicking it.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 你给每个人都看一眼
Tasha: Show it to everyone.
Katrina: 你你吧
Katrina: You, you.
Katrina: 弹舌吗
Katrina: Tongue pop?
Alice:你去学俄语吧
Alice: You should learn Russian.
Tasha: 买个羽绒吧
Tasha: Buy a down jacket.
Katrina: 我不会
Katrina: I don't know how.
Tasha: 还有个薄荷
Tasha: There's also a mint one.
Tasha: 不一定能买的到
Tasha: Might not be able to buy it though.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And that's it.
Shure:  我原来也不会
Shure: I didn't know how either.
Shure:  我记得有一天滑个滑板
Shure: I remember one day I was skateboarding.
Tasha:奶粉也不一定
Tasha: Baby formula might not be available either.
Shure:  然后一下就会了
Shure: And suddenly I just knew how.
Jake:再拍一次管理一下
Jake: Let's film this again and manage it.
Jake: 能管理的了吗
Jake: Can we manage it?
Shure:  管理不了
Shure: Can't manage it.
Lucia: 管理一下管理一下
Lucia: Let's manage it, manage it.
Jake: 管理一下好
Jake: Okay, let's manage it.
Shure:  怎么管理一下
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Shure:  就是看着像正常人类一点
Shure: Just try to look more normal.
Katrina: 禁止禁止 10秒钟
Katrina: Stop, stop for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那很难那很难
Jake: That's really hard, really hard.
Jake: 这回来个10秒的
Jake: Let's do 10 seconds this time.
Shure:  10秒
Shure: 10 seconds.
Katrina:  10秒他保持不了10秒进去
Katrina: He can't keep it for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那就酝酿一会
Jake: Then let's take a moment.
Jake: 你的音效声音
Jake: Your sound effects.
Lucia: 看大家的管理成果
Lucia: Look at everyone's management results.
Tasha: 表情管理成果吗
Tasha: Expression management results?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Katrina:  可以无所谓
Katrina: It's okay, doesn't matter.
Alice: 鸦雀无声
Alice: Quiet as a mouse.
Lucia: 鸦雀无声
Lucia: Quiet as a mouse.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's fine.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina:  还缺啥吗你刚说
Katrina: Are we missing anything, like you said?
Tasha: 还缺保鲜膜
Tasha: We still need cling film.
Tasha: 你们买一下
Tasha: You guys buy it.
Katrina: 买了
Katrina: Already bought it.
Lucia: 买了我们买了保鲜膜
Lucia: We bought the cling film.
Lucia: 保鲜膜买了
Lucia: Got the cling film.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it.
Tasha: 还有什么
Tasha: What else?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crust
Alice:荔浦芋头
Alice: Lipu taro
Tasha: 芋头没有
Tasha: No taro
Shure:  杨老板头大了
Shure: Jake's got a big head now
Alice:没了
Alice: None
Tasha: 薄荷买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy mint?
Katrina:  没有买薄荷哎
Katrina: Didn't buy any mint
Alice: 没有薄荷可能
Alice: There might be no mint
Tasha: 是没有薄荷
Tasha: There's no mint
Jake:没有这些都很便宜听起来
Jake: Without these, everything sounds cheap
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  知道什么叫聚沙成塔
Shure: Do you know the saying "every little bit helps"?
Shure:  压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗
Shure: Or "the straw that broke the camel's back"?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crust
Katrina: 薄荷蛋挞皮薄荷
Katrina: Mint tart crust mint
Jake: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Jake: The last tart crust
Lucia: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Lucia: The last tart crust
Alice: 实在没有薄荷
Alice: Really no mint
Alice:要不然下楼摘点叶子吧
Alice: How about we go downstairs and pick some leaves?
Shure:  咱们去那个那什么
Shure: Let's go to that place
Shure:  买一盆新的就行
Shure: Buy a new pot, it's fine
Alice: 把我们那花剪点当装饰
Alice: Let's cut some flowers from our place for decoration
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No
Katrina:  薄荷好像确实没看见
Katrina: Seems like there's really no mint
Shure:  烘焙区是不是在前面
Shure: The baking area should be up ahead
Tasha: 那吗
Tasha: There?
Tasha: 对不是这儿
Tasha: Yeah, not here
Jake: 能带我起来吗
Jake: Can you help me up?
Jake: 啊小心小心
Jake: Ah, careful, careful
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, no, no
Lucia: 这些非工作人员请勿触碰
Lucia: Non-staff members, please do not touch
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What happened?
Tasha: 他说烘焙区里面有烘蛋挞
Tasha: He said there's baked tarts in the baking area
Jake:我也不碰了
Jake: I won't touch it either
Lucia: 小心危险
Lucia: Careful, it's dangerous
Katrina: 老北京豆汁
Katrina: Old Beijing mung bean soup
Katrina: 拿两盒豆汁
Katrina: Take two boxes of mung bean soup
Lucia: 但实话说
Lucia: But honestly
Lucia: 我也挺好奇
Lucia: I'm also curious
Lucia: 他们上面那个Logic chain是干嘛用的
Lucia: What's the Logic chain used for?
Lucia: 我们诶这个好可爱
Lucia: 啊扫描一下
Alice:啥呀
Jake: 从上往下拍会好吗
Lucia: 呃会好一点
Lucia: 一般来说这个角度会显得人脸瘦一点
Jake:那就让他从上往下拍
Jake: 齐吧人不齐
Lucia: 我们可以比个心
Jake:哎呦我去哈哈哈
Lucia: 那就等10秒
Jake: 可以有点糊啊
Jake:这聚焦怎么聚哪去了
Lucia: 谢谢好像有那么一点点糊
Lucia: 但你是清楚的
Jake: 聚我头上去了
Jake: 我这个目标太大
Lucia: 没事说明他这个抓住重点想拍老板
Jake: 现在对了好
Katrina:  我俩还比心吗
Lucia: 啊可以或者
Lucia: Ah, sure, or...
Katrina: 又来哈哈哈
Katrina: Here we go again, hahaha.
Lucia: 又没聚住吗
Lucia: Did it not work again?
Shure: 5秒就行
Shure: 5 seconds is enough.
Katrina:  他俩找蛋挞皮去了吗
Katrina: Did they go to find the tart crusts?
Jake: 好要压死我了
Jake: Alright, I’m getting crushed here.
Jake:蛋挞皮
Jake: Tart crusts.
Jake: 哦在那
Jake: Oh, over there.
Shure:  哦你们看过人类宇宙探索编辑部吗
Shure: Oh, have you guys seen the Human Space Exploration Editing Department?
Katrina: 没看没看过
Katrina: No, haven't seen it.
Katrina: 当然可火了没看
Katrina: Of course it’s popular, but I haven’t seen it.
Shure:  一个算是文艺片吧
Shure: It's kind of an art film, I guess.
Katrina:  什么呀薄荷
Katrina: What, mint?
Tasha: 没有问过服务台了
Tasha: Haven't asked the service desk.
Katrina:  薄荷和那个什么芋泥
Katrina: Mint and what, taro?
Katrina:  还有那个蛋挞皮都没有
Katrina: And they don’t have the tart crusts either.
Alice: 对别的都可以
Alice: Yeah, everything else is fine.
Tasha: 但是蛋挞液自己做的话
Tasha: But if you're making the custard yourself...
Tasha: 要旺仔牛奶就行了
Tasha: You just need Wangzai milk.
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, got it.
Lucia: 这个是用来送打包外卖的
Lucia: This is used for delivering takeout.
Lucia: 刚才看到一个袋子过去
Lucia: I just saw a bag go by.
Lucia: 我终于知道它是干什么的了
Lucia: I finally know what it's for.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  自己做麻烦吗
Katrina: Is it troublesome to make it yourself?
Tasha: 不麻烦
Tasha: Not at all.
Jake:他就是他
Jake: He is who he is.
Jake:走几步很难吗
Jake: Is it hard to walk a few steps?
Katrina: 我看看啊
Katrina: Let me see.
Alice: 要放淡奶油吧
Alice: Should we add some whipped cream?
Lucia: 可能是
Lucia: Maybe.
Tasha: 对淡奶油炼乳白砂糖蛋液
Tasha: Yes, whipped cream, condensed milk, white sugar, and egg yolk.
Lucia: 给大家造成一种高科技的错觉
Lucia: It creates an illusion of high-tech.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 蛋蛋液就行了
Tasha: Just the egg yolk is fine.
Tasha: 还有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: And also Wangzai milk.
Alice: 蛋挞皮的话那个
Alice: For the tart crust, that one...
Lucia: 但实际上这玩意很像蒸汽朋克时代那种话筒
Lucia: But actually, it looks like a steampunk era microphone.
Alice:蛋挞皮能自己做吗蛋挞皮是不是得
Alice: Can we make the tart crust ourselves? Does it need...
Katrina:  可以外送了
Katrina: It can be delivered.
Alice: 对闪溢的
Alice: Yes, it's shiny.
Tasha: 但是我想要
Tasha: But I want...
Tasha: 叫什么奥昆
Tasha: What's it called, Okun?
Tasha: 奥昆
Tasha: Okun.
Tasha: 呃精品
Tasha: Uh, premium.
Katrina: 就是你对牌子有要求吗
Katrina: Do you have a preference for brands?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crust.
Jake: 大肠杆菌
Jake: E. coli.
Shure:  对大肠杆菌
Shure: Yes, E. coli.
Shure:  大肠杆菌
Shure: E. coli.
Katrina: 你那指甲还挺好看的
Katrina: Your nails look nice.
Lucia: 撒了那种
Lucia: Sprinkle those.
Lucia: 就是生日蛋糕上面那种小糖碎的草莓
Lucia: Like those little sugar bits on birthday cakes with strawberries.
Katrina: 是裸色吗
Katrina: Is it nude color?
Katrina: 我我我特想抠
Katrina: I really want to pick at it.
Jake:啊这甜甜圈
Jake: Oh, this donut.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Jake:吃了一口
Jake: Took a bite.
Katrina: 如果我镶钻了
Katrina: If I had diamonds on it...
Tasha: 我也是我我刚做的
Tasha: Same here, I just did it.
Shure:  这后面是一个姜饼人
Shure: There's a gingerbread man behind us.
Shure:  所以就是没有
Shure: So there's none.
Alice:没有只能外卖买了吧
Alice: We can't get it, so we have to order takeout.
Jake:是一个
Jake: It's a...
Jake: 猫头鹰啊
Jake: Owl.
Lucia: 姜饼
Lucia: Gingerbread.
Jake:姜饼人
Jake: Gingerbread man.
Tasha: 我们买个旺仔牛奶就走吧
Tasha: Let's just buy some Wangzai Milk and leave.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where's the person?
Jake:姜饼猫头鹰怎么了
Jake: What's up with the gingerbread owl?
Katrina:  旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wangzai Milk.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai Milk.
Tasha: 走,go
Tasha: Let's go, go.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And then there's nothing.
Jake: 好在哪里
Jake: Okay, where is it?
Tasha: 在哪里牛奶区吧
Tasha: Maybe in the milk section?
Katrina: 好像没有逛到旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Seems like we didn't pass by the Wangzai Milk section.
Tasha: 他们家不一定有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: They might not have Wangzai Milk.
Katrina: 人 类是这样的
Katrina: Humans are like this.
Katrina:  因为人活着累
Katrina: Because living is tiring.
Shure:  洗了算了
Shure: Forget it, let's wash it.
Katrina:  哎呀对不起
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Alice:哎呦哦没事
Alice: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: Nothing.
Shure: 完了追尾了
Shure: Oh no, we had a fender bender.
Katrina: 追尾
Katrina: Fender bender.
Alice: 因为他们家有自自营的那种牛奶
Alice: Because they have their own brand of milk.
Lucia: 算了吧那就走吧
Lucia: Never mind, let's just go.
Katrina:  也没有吗
Katrina: They don't have it either?
Katrina:  没有就不一样了
Katrina: If not, it's different.
Katrina:  是不是跟他们有品牌竞争啊
Katrina: Are they competing with the brand?
Katrina: 利益冲突
Katrina: Conflict of interest.
Tasha: 因为他们有那个自营的
Tasha: Because they have their own brand.
Katrina: 自营嘛对
Katrina: Right, their own brand.
Shure:  都是他们的竞品哦
Shure: They're all competitors.
Lucia: 所以盒马对标当然是
Lucia: So Hema is definitely competing.
Katrina: 全员竞品啊
Katrina: Everyone's a competitor.
Katrina: 汇源果汁也没有
Katrina: Even Huiyuan Juice isn't available.
Tasha: 你是因为镜头在录
Tasha: It's because the camera is recording.
Katrina: 桃汁也没有
Katrina: There's no peach juice either.
Jake:没有那你为什么要打我
Jake: No, then why did you hit me?
Shure: 那种山姆吧我感觉
Shure: Maybe it's that Sam's stuff, I think.
Katrina: 自营为什么不出桃汁呢
Katrina: Why doesn't their own brand have peach juice?
Jake:为了把你丢这个钻石丢在我的身上啊
Jake: So you can throw this diamond onto me, huh?
Lucia: 如果自营有同品类的话会形成竞争而且这样他们可以降低成本
Lucia: If their own brand has similar products, there will be competition, and they can lower costs.
Jake:就是你打我然后丢了钻石
Jake: So you hit me and then lost the diamond.
Lucia: 不管是制造成本还是
Lucia: Whether it's manufacturing costs or...
Katrina:  嗯还有听你讲经济学原理
Katrina: Hmm, listening to you talk about economics.
Tasha: 这里有汉堡
Tasha: There are burgers here.
Shure:  好像现在那个美团也在搞
Shure: It seems like Meituan is also doing it now.
Shure:  那个小象超市但是他目前都是线上的
Shure: That Xiaoxiang supermarket, but it's all online for now.
Katrina: 啊我刚看到了
Katrina: Ah, I just saw it.
Shure:  而且
Shure: And...
Shure:  咱们那个地方还不在那个小象
Shure: Our place isn't in Xiaoxiang's...
Shure:  超市配送区
Shure: Delivery area.
Lucia: 如果他能掌控整个供应链的话
Lucia: If they can control the entire supply chain...
Lucia: 就能把成本降到最低
Lucia: They can minimize costs.
Lucia: 但是像京东什么物流这些都是自己做的嘛
Lucia: But like JD, their logistics are all self-operated.
Katrina:  咱自己自助吗
Katrina: Are we doing self-checkout?
Shure:  而且盒马他们那个配送费你满39
Shure: And Hema, if you spend over 39, they waive the delivery fee.
Shure:  他就免配送
Shure: It's really convenient.
Shure:  就是其实很 方便
Shure: So we should scan ourselves.
Katrina: 我们自己扫
Katrina: We should scan ourselves.
Katrina: 还是去那自己扫吧
Katrina: Let's just go scan ourselves.
Alice:开始结账了吗
Alice: Are we starting to check out?
Lucia: 那里有一个取消交易
Lucia: There's a cancel transaction option there.
Katrina: 这是谁的
Katrina: Whose is this?
Lucia: 我这个头发怎么老是乱七八糟
Lucia: Why is my hair always so messy?
Tasha: 那肯定要借嘛
Tasha: Of course, you need to borrow it.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure:  到您了
Shure: It's your turn.
Jake: 到已经扫完了
Jake: It's already scanned.
Shure:  没有得先扫会员码
Shure: No, you need to scan the membership code first.
Jake: 哦那我也没有啊
Jake: Oh, I don't have it either.
Alice: 普通会员不就行了吗
Alice: A regular membership will do.
Shure:  不是就必须
Shure: No, it has to be...
Katrina: 你们谁有会员
Katrina: Does anyone have a membership?
Alice:普通会员就可以了
Alice: A regular membership is fine.
Tasha: 找88会员
Tasha: Look for 88 VIP members.
Shure:  我来吧
Shure: I'll do it.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Okay, fine.
Katrina:  88VIP有盒马吗
Katrina: Does 88VIP include Hema?
Tasha: 找88会呃不是88折盒马哦
Tasha: No, 88VIP is not 88% off at Hema.
Jake: 哦所以你有是吧
Jake: Oh, so you have it, right?
Tasha: 呃我我呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, I, I, uh, wait a second.
Jake: 修硕有还是
Jake: Does Shure have it, or...
Lucia: 我甚至没有盒马APP
Lucia: I don't even have the Hema app.
Shure:  我有盒马APP
Shure: I have the Hema app.
Jake:我也我也没有我也没有
Jake: Me neither, I don't have it either.
Shure:  但我好像卡里没有那么多钱
Shure: But I don't think I have enough money in my account.
Tasha: 对我我还有优惠券
Tasha: Right, I still have coupons.
Alice: 你点不到啊
Alice: You can't use it.
Lucia: 盒马是必须要用APP才能结账的
Lucia: Hema requires the app to check out.
Lucia: 我刚回国的时候跟我爸逛了一趟
Lucia: When I first came back to the country, I went shopping with my dad.
Lucia: 发现只能用APP结账
Lucia: I found out you can only check out using the app.
Lucia: 我就出去了什么也没买
Lucia: So I left without buying anything.
Jake:哈哈哈那你要坐两个拖车的话
Jake: Hahaha, so if you have to use two carts, how do you put them back?
Jake: 然后怎么放回去
Jake: Then how do you put them back?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 就是因为那天拿的东西其实也不太行
Lucia: Plus, the stuff we got that day wasn't even that good.
Jake:打的东西还行
Jake: The stuff you got was okay.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Alice:哎为什么用不了呢
Alice: Hey, why can't we use it?
Shure: 杨老板要不给给你弄一个
Shure: Jake, do you want me to set it up for you?
Shure:  好啊支付宝有吧
Shure: Sure, do you have Alipay?
Jake:好
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 支付宝有啊
Jake: Alipay works?
Shure:  那支付宝也行
Shure: Alipay works too.
Shure:  支付宝里有二维码
Shure: There's a QR code in Alipay.
Jake: 支付宝还是有
Jake: Alipay still works.
Alice: 我打开APP
Alice: I'll open the app.
Alice: 不知道为什么点不了二维码
Alice: Don't know why I can't click the QR code.
Alice: 是不是因为我们开着那个啥的
Alice: Is it because we have that thing on?
Alice: 哦但你一关那个啥不就停那啥了吗
Alice: Oh, but if you turn that off, won't it stop that thing?
Alice:把我家地址录上了没关系吧
Alice: It's okay if I put my home address in, right?
Lucia: 他们会处理好像
Lucia: They should handle it, I think.
Tasha: 有有有有
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, they do.
Jake:对回头会看一眼
Jake: Yeah, we'll look at it later.
Jake: 那个看一眼这谁的手机
Jake: Look at this, whose phone is this?
Katrina: 这谁的手机他的吗
Katrina: Whose phone is this? His?
Jake: 这个压力还是挺大的
Jake: This is quite stressful.
Jake: 把你们的片都看一遍
Jake: Watch all of your clips.
Lucia: 我加油
Lucia: I'll do my best.
Katrina: 你用试试
Katrina: You try it.
Shure: 减20块钱
Shure: Reduce it by 20 bucks.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But it's okay.
Lucia: 因为我觉得我看手机的时候
Lucia: Because when I look at my phone
Katrina: 用你的也可以啊
Lucia: 肯定会看到我家地址
Lucia: I'm sure I'll see my home address.
Lucia: 或者之类的类似的东西
Lucia: Or something similar like that.
Tasha: 我一打开APP就默认我家地址
Tasha: When I open an app, it defaults to my home address.
Tasha: 我的外送地址
Tasha: My delivery address.
Katrina: 不是你有会员吗
Katrina: Don't you have a membership?
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我今天打开淘宝查材料包的时候也是
Lucia: When I opened Taobao to check the material package today, same thing.
Katrina:  你就用你的呗
Katrina: Just use yours.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  用你的然后让他给你报呗
Katrina: Use yours and let him report it.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Jake: 发生了什么
Jake: What happened?
Shure:  没事可以开始了
Shure: It's fine, we can start.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我们要不要再拿一个车过来
Lucia: Should we bring another car?
Shure:  再拿一个道吧
Shure: Let's get another lane.
Jake: 插个电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Alice: 我也是吧
Alice: Me too.
Alice: 我能看到
Alice: I can see it.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:咱咱眼睛插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug it in.
Jake:别别最后挂掉了
Jake: Don't let it die.
Jake: 你的电还在吗
Jake: Is your battery still there?
Jake: 我们这些东西怎么带走啊
Jake: How do we take these things away?
Tasha: 袋子装
Tasha: Use a bag.
Jake:袋子哦
Jake: A bag, huh?
Lucia: 有种给自己脑子接口一样的感觉
Lucia: Feels like plugging into my brain.
Shure: 先扫俩袋子然后边扫边装
Shure: First scan two bags, then scan and pack.
Tasha: 就跟自己是个AI机器人给自己充电
Tasha: It's like being an AI robot charging itself.
Katrina: 在哪扫袋子
Katrina: Where do we scan the bags?
Jake:给充电对对对电没了
Jake: Charge it, right, right, it's out of battery.
Jake: 我可熟练了
Jake: I'm really skilled at this.
Jake: 没有人比我更熟练
Jake: No one is more skilled than me.
Katrina: 哇这积分积爽了
Lucia: 哇我去看一下
Lucia: Wow, let me go check it out.
Jake:我来帮您来
Jake: I'll help you with that.
Jake:我觉得自己这确实有点难
Jake: I think this is actually a bit hard.
Jake:多少拿着点啊
Jake: Hold it a bit, okay?
Jake: 挺好这个袋子
Jake: This bag is nice.
Jake:疼吗
Jake: Does it hurt?
Lucia: 我们可以把这个袋先扫一下
Lucia: We can scan this bag first.
Lucia: 他说要扫一下然后好吧拿了俩
Lucia: He said to scan it first, alright, took two.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好哎好了
Tasha: Okay, it's done.
Jake:好了啊
Jake: Done, huh?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 就跟打针一样
Tasha: Just like getting a shot.
Jake:哈哈哈
Lucia: 然后就可以往里走
Lucia: Then you can go inside.
Jake: 好了哈哈
Jake: Done, haha.
Lucia: 怎么感觉好像两个袋也不够
Lucia: Why does it feel like two bags are not enough?
Tasha: 可以先结账
Tasha: We can checkout first.
Tasha: 这个已经优惠10块钱了
Tasha: This one already has a 10 yuan discount.
Katrina:  先结一部分是吗
Katrina: Checkout part of it first, right?
Tasha: 对然后再扫
Tasha: Yes, then scan again.
Tasha: 然后还有两张券
Tasha: And there are two more coupons.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Jake: 他是什么
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 每100每500省10块
Jake: Every 100, every 500 saves 10 yuan.
Tasha: 不是我的红包券好不好
Tasha: No, it's my red envelope coupon, okay?
Tasha: 我在牺牲我自己
Tasha: I'm sacrificing myself.
Shure:  哈哈哦哦
Shure: Haha, oh, oh.
Jake:哦哦可以感感谢老板捐10块钱
Jake: Oh, oh, alright, thanks, boss, for donating 10 yuan.
Katrina: 那就先付吧
Katrina: Then let's pay first.
Jake: 好这是10块钱捐赠是吧
Jake: Alright, so this is a 10 yuan donation, right?
Jake: 哎这些扫没扫呢
Jake: Hey, have these been scanned?
Katrina: 扫了的
Katrina: Yes, they have.
Shure:  哎怎么扫
Shure: Hey, how to scan?
Jake:应该怎么扫阿里pay吗
Jake: Should we scan with Alipay?
Lucia: 都是扫过的呢
Lucia: They've all been scanned.
Shure:  都是扫过的
Shure: They've all been scanned.
Lucia: 这个车里的车还没扫呢
Lucia: The cars inside haven't been scanned yet.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 那边应该都扫过了
Lucia: That side should all be scanned.
Lucia: 那这呃这俩袋子也不够好像
Lucia: These two bags don't seem to be enough.
Lucia: 系一下别混一块了
Lucia: Tie them up so they don't get mixed up.
Katrina:  行吧再再要一个袋子是吧
Katrina: Okay, let's get another bag then.
Alice:心痛
Alice: Heartbreaking.
Tasha: 真的能付成功吗可以吧
Tasha: Can we really make the payment? We can, right?
Tasha: 哦可以的
Tasha: Oh, we can.
Katrina:  我们怎么提回去
Katrina: How do we take it back?
Katrina: 打车就在楼下
Katrina: Get a cab, it's just downstairs.
Jake:100刀100新币
Jake: 100 dollars, 100 SGD.
Shure:  100新币对
Shure: 100 SGD, yeah.
Jake:一车就100新币
Jake: One car costs 100 SGD.
Shure:  不到100新币
Shure: Less than 100 SGD.
Jake: 我每次一塑料袋100新币
Jake: Every plastic bag is 100 SGD.
Shure:  杨老板就是大气
Shure: Jake is so generous.
Lucia: 没到一车呢
Lucia: It's not even a full car yet.
Lucia: 这边才装了
Lucia: This side is only partially filled.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 那可能是400金币
Jake: Then it might be 400 gold coins.
Jake: 我估计
Jake: I guess.
Tasha: 这个结过账的
Tasha: This one's already paid for.
Lucia: 对这这里也都结了
Lucia: Yeah, this side is all paid for too.
Lucia: 这里这里好像还没结吧
Lucia: This side doesn't seem to be paid yet, right?
Katrina:  放台上没有
Katrina: Didn't put it on the counter?
Katrina:  没有放台上
Katrina: Didn't put it on the counter.
Alice:这怎么放呢
Alice: How do we place this?
Lucia: 先把这的都挪到这
Lucia: Move everything here first.
Jake:再来一个车
Jake: Get another car.
Jake: 我再来一辆车
Jake: I'll get another car.
Jake: 再来一辆车
Jake: Get another car.
Jake:不用用了哦OK好嘞
Jake: No need, OK, got it.
Lucia: 就把这个都挪过来然后
Lucia: Just move all these over here and then...
Lucia: 那边装完的放到这个车里
Lucia: Put the filled ones into this car.
Katrina: 就是没结是吗
Katrina: So it's not paid yet, right?
Jake:结账要先下载好盒马APP才能结账
Jake: You need to download the Hema app first to make the payment.
Katrina: 那就交换一下
Katrina: Then let's swap it.
Katrina: 在那边装袋吧
Katrina: Let's bag it over there.
Tasha: 新加坡没有盒马是吗
Tasha: Is there no Hema in Singapore?
Jake: 应该没有
Jake: Probably not.
Jake: 我探索的也不多
Jake: I haven't explored much.
Jake: 那新加坡那边是什么样的超市
Jake: What kind of supermarkets are there in Singapore?
Lucia: 就这种天生纤维的这种
Lucia: The ones with natural fibers.
Katrina: 呀感觉还需要袋子
Katrina: Yeah, we might need another bag.
Lucia: 全食吗
Lucia: Whole Foods, maybe?
Jake:不是就是他们有一家fire price
Jake: No, they have a store called Fire Price.
Jake: 应该是政府给了很多补贴的
Jake: I think it gets a lot of government subsidies.
Jake: 哦叫fire price
Jake: Oh, it's called Fire Price.
Jake: 很便宜对对对
Jake: It's very cheap, yeah.
Lucia: 这个线老是让我弄得很奇怪
Lucia: This wire always gets me confused.
Jake:哎我帮你
Jake: Let me help you.
Jake:要不就是这个放你后面
Jake: Maybe place it behind you.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hi, hi.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Lucia: 有点卷插头
Lucia: The plug's a bit twisted.
Tasha: 结过账了
Tasha: All paid for.
Katrina:  对方台上都是结过账
Katrina: Yeah, everything on the counter is paid for.
Lucia: 给他弄直一点
Lucia: Straighten it out for him.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 要不然好像我动着动着
Lucia: Otherwise, it keeps moving around.
Katrina: 哈真买了很多饮料
Katrina: Wow, we bought a lot of drinks.
Jake:这个是久经验证的插电姿势
Jake: This is the tried-and-true way to plug it in.
Jake:对其实在后面绕过来最好后面贴个胶
Jake: Actually, it's best to loop it around the back and tape it.
Lucia: 你是做过多少次这样类似的实验了
Lucia: How many times have you done similar experiments?
Jake: 对这个1月份到的
Jake: I got this in January.
Jake: 我带着这个到处
Jake: I take it everywhere.
Jake: 就看比赛啊
Jake: Just to watch games.
Jake: 进城都带着这个东西
Jake: I bring it to every game.
Jake: 哦看比赛还可以那
Jake: Oh, it's good for watching games.
Lucia: 那会把比赛整个
Lucia: Do you record and model the games?
Lucia: 记录建模下来吗
Lucia: Like the whole thing?
Jake: 这个不会
Jake: No, I can't.
Jake:这个不会这个就版权的问题
Jake: No, because of copyright issues.
Jake: 只能扫扫进场的仪式
Jake: I can only scan the entrance ceremonies.
Tasha: 那
Tasha: So...
Tasha: 那看电影的时候能把电影记下来吗
Tasha: Can you remember the movie while watching it?
Alice:这个放别的地
Alice: Put this somewhere else.
Lucia: 那也不行吧
Lucia: That won't work either.
Lucia: 也牵涉版权哦
Lucia: It involves copyright too.
Katrina: 红薯掉地熬出来了
Katrina: The sweet potato fell on the ground and was boiled.
Lucia: 这不就是枪版
Lucia: Isn't that just a bootleg copy?
Jake: 哈哈哈这就是枪版
Jake: Hahaha, that's a bootleg.
Lucia: 3D枪版
Lucia: 3D bootleg.
Jake:这就是枪版
Jake: That's a bootleg.
Lucia: 坐在电影院的体验
Lucia: The experience of sitting in the theater.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 这得封一下
Katrina: This needs to be sealed.
Jake:我带一个这个进去给你打出来
Jake: I'll take this in and record it for you.
Alice:放点轻的吧
Alice: Put something lighter.
Jake:哈哈我就这个装备进电影院
Jake: Haha, I'll just take this gear into the theater.
Alice:我觉得这个有点够呛了
Alice: I think that's a bit too much.
Lucia: 感觉很酷炫的样子
Lucia: It looks pretty cool though.
Alice:这拖着底抱
Alice: Dragging it around.
Katrina: 放点小饮料吧
Katrina: Just bring some small drinks.
Katrina:  这什么呀
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  再来一个
Shure: Another one.
Jake: 感觉两条腿都要断
Jake: Feels like my legs are going to break.
Shure:  再去拿两个袋
Shure: Go get two more bags.
小Lucia: 再来两个袋
Little Lucia: Get two more bags.
Jake: 耍赖吗
Jake: Are you cheating?
Katrina: 魔芋块
Katrina: Konjac pieces.
Jake: 这边有冰块
Jake: There are ice cubes here.
Jake: 保鲜冰块
Jake: Fresh-keeping ice cubes.
Jake: 保鲜冰块能吃吗
Jake: Can we eat fresh-keeping ice cubes?
Alice: 呃不能吃
Alice: Uh, no.
Jake: 好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 但是你可以带
Tasha: But you can bring them.
Tasha: 呃也不用吧
Tasha: Uh, no need actually.
Jake: 我们用不着吧
Jake: We don't need them, right?
Katrina:  要多少钱拿
Katrina: How much do we need to take?
Jake: 编辑一下
Jake: Edit it a bit.
Lucia: 矫正视力
Lucia: Correcting vision.
Katrina: 你那个券是多少
Katrina: How much is that coupon?
Katrina: 满多少
Katrina: What's the minimum spend?
Jake: 我们视力都有问题
Jake: We all have vision problems.
Katrina: 500啊
Katrina: 500, huh?
Jake: 就是我们6个人一样的问题
Jake: It's the same problem for all six of us.
Alice:这个结过了吗
Alice: Is this one done?
Jake: 病友
Jake: Patient.
Katrina:  都结过了
Katrina: They're all done.
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Alice: 放点放点占位置的
Alice: Put some, put some placeholders.
Jake: 对呃这是全景
Jake: Yeah, uh, this is the full view.
Jake: 博主博主
Jake: Blogger, blogger.
Tasha: 探店的博主
Tasha: Food review blogger.
Jake: 对对6人博主
Jake: Yeah, yeah, six bloggers.
Jake: 博主探店
Jake: Bloggers reviewing food.
Katrina:  博主能送两个菜吗
Katrina: Can bloggers get two dishes for free?
Jake: 对网上见就是好吧
Jake: Yeah, if you see it online, it's fine.
Jake: 哈哈哈自己开个超市是吧
Jake: Hahaha, you can open your own supermarket, right?
Jake: 自己开个盒马
Jake: Open your own Hema store.
Lucia: 这个也做美食
Lucia: This also does food.
Lucia: 哈哈对我们有美食专家
Lucia: Haha, yeah, we have a food expert.
Tasha: 哎等一下别再扫了
Tasha: Hey, wait a minute, stop scanning.
Tasha: 还还可以用下一个券呢
Tasha: You can use the next coupon.
Alice: 还没到500呢
Alice: It's not 500 yet.
Tasha: 不用到500
Tasha: Doesn't need to be 500.
Alice:那你多少
Alice: Then how much do you need?
Tasha: 满20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Just 20. Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈满20满20
Jake: Hahaha, just 20, just 20.
Alice:来最后一个
Alice: Okay, the last one.
Alice:随便拿几个券
Alice: Just grab a few coupons.
Tasha: 我不确定满多少
Tasha: I'm not sure how much.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check.
Alice: 你先你先把那个满500的那个10块钱用了
Alice: First, use the 10 yuan off 500 coupon.
Jake: 凑到了500
Jake: Made it to 500.
Tasha: 满49和满29哎
Tasha: 49 and 29, hey.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 first.
Tasha: 满29的水果券
Tasha: 29 fruit coupon.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 first.
Tasha: 这个是用的什么券
Tasha: Which coupon is this?
Shure:  哎差不多差不多
Shure: It's about right, about right.
Shure:  无所谓无所谓
Shure: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Tasha: 这是水果卷
Tasha: This is the fruit coupon.
Katrina: 要吗
Katrina: Do you want it?
Jake: 他一天能扫这么多
Jake: He can scan this many in a day.
Tasha: 还有一个海鲜券
Tasha: And there's a seafood coupon.
Shure:  给杨老板省了不到一新币
Shure: Saved Jake less than a dollar.
Alice:有海鲜吗
Alice: Is there any seafood?
Katrina: 海鲜是不是扫完了
Katrina: Is the seafood all scanned?
Alice:我们买海鲜了吗
Alice: Did we buy seafood?
Katrina:  没有买海鲜
Katrina: No, we didn't buy any seafood.
Jake: 一新币很重要的
Jake: One dollar is very important.
Tasha: 那好吧那就扫不完了
Tasha: Well, then we can't scan all of it.
Jake: 一新币可以
Jake: One dollar can...
Katrina: 那就那就这一个卷是吧
Katrina: So there's just this one coupon, right?
Lucia: 虾虾虾滑算海鲜吗
Lucia: Do shrimp balls count as seafood?
Shure:  可口可乐能买吗
Shure: Can we buy Coca-Cola?
Jake: 买不了哈哈哈
Jake: Can't buy it, haha.
Katrina: 不算不算
Katrina: It doesn't count.
Tasha: 虾滑算海鲜吗
Tasha: Do shrimp balls count as seafood?
Tasha: 完了那部分被我
Tasha: Oh no, that part was scanned by us.
Tasha: 们扫掉了
Tasha: We scanned it.
Shure:  没事的没事的
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 算了吧
Katrina: Forget it.
Shure:  就这样吧
Shure: Let's just leave it like this.
Katrina: 买了1,000块钱
Katrina: We spent 1,000 dollars.
Jake: 1新币能干嘛呢
Jake: What can one dollar do?
Katrina:  省十块也没有
Katrina: It didn't even save ten dollars.
Tasha: 好吧那扫吧
Tasha: Alright, then scan it.
Katrina:  那就只有这一个券是吗
Katrina: So there's just this one coupon, right?
Tasha: 这个是不是扫过了
Tasha: Did we scan this one?
Alice:我这个扫了吗
Alice: Did I scan this one?
Tasha: 坐公交或许
Tasha: Maybe it could be used for a bus ride.
Jake: 坐不了哈哈
Jake: No, it can't, haha.
Katrina:  这两个扫了
Katrina: These two are scanned.
Katrina: 这个我忘了
Katrina: I forgot about this one.
Katrina:  这个午餐肉扫了吗
Katrina: Did we scan the luncheon meat?
Alice:这还没扫
Alice: This one hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 呃得一块七
Jake: Uh, it's one dollar seventy.
Shure:  哎呀呀呀
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  你又加了一个
Shure: You added another one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  那什么你刚才不小心加了一个
Shure: You accidentally added another one.
Katrina:  那个但是他是×1
Katrina: But he's ×1
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: This one?
Katrina: 不是 这个这个这个
Katrina: No, this one, this one, this one.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  不是不是
Jake: 不知道耶
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  这没扫吧
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, right?
Jake: 可能
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 国内也是两块钱
Jake: It's also two yuan in our country.
Katrina: 这没扫没扫
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 没错没错
Jake: That's right, that's right.
Jake: 这边也是两
Jake: It's two here too.
Jake: 那边也两块钱
Jake: It's also two yuan there.
Jake: 国内刷支付宝只要这
Jake: In our country, using Alipay only costs this.
Alice: 感觉不能再装了
Alice: I don't think we can fit more.
Alice:这个装巨多饮料
Alice: This bag already has a lot of drinks.
Tasha: 这个扫过了是吧
Tasha: This one has been scanned, right?
Alice: 扫过了这都是扫过的
Alice: Yes, everything here has been scanned.
Katrina:  桌上都是扫过的
Katrina: Everything on the table has been scanned.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure:  不好意思
Shure: My bad.
Tasha: 这个真的还能装沉的吗
Tasha: Can this really hold more weight?
Tasha: 小瓶子放进去OK
Tasha: Small bottles are fine to put in.
Tasha: 主要是这个重量
Tasha: It's mainly the weight.
Tasha: 这里面好像饮料比较多
Tasha: It seems like there are more drinks in here.
Tasha: 别别别压他了别压他了
Tasha: No, no, don't press it down.
Tasha: 好了万一托着底抱托着底抱
Tasha: Okay, hold it from the bottom just in case, hold it from the bottom.
Jake: 我来扎我来扎
Jake: Let me tie it, let me tie it.
Lucia: 这个这把这个拿起来
Lucia: Take this, lift this up.
Lucia: 然后把这个放在这扎
Lucia: Then put this here and tie it.
Lucia: 可能好扎一些
Lucia: It might be easier to tie.
Shure:  妈呀这个一会
Shure: Oh my, this is...
Lucia: 这个好重
Lucia: This is so heavy.
Katrina: 这水自带的吧
Katrina: This water is included, right?
Tasha: 分两车吧
Tasha: Let's split it into two carts.
Jake: 再来辆车
Jake: Let's get another cart.
Jake: 我来开车
Jake: I'll drive.
Jake: 我去开车
Jake: I'll go drive.
Lucia: 这个这个袋子有点太重了
Lucia: This bag is a bit too heavy.
Lucia: 一个可能撑不住
Lucia: One might not be enough.
Tasha: 我感觉应该分散一点吧
Tasha: I feel like we should spread it out a bit.
Shure: 这撑不住的
Shure: This can't hold up.
Shure:  这个太太那什么了
Shure: This is just too much.
Lucia: 就是得抱着
Lucia: We just have to hold it.
Lucia: 拿两瓶饮料重要出来
Lucia: Take out two bottles of drinks.
Lucia: 然后放到这里面可以吗
Lucia: And put them in here, okay?
Lucia: 这个够重这重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy enough?
Alice:这个倒是不重
Alice: This one isn't heavy.
Shure:  不要把一个鸡蛋装在同一个篮子里哦
Shure: Don't put all your eggs in one basket.
Katrina:  放多个篮子了
Katrina: Put them in multiple baskets.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 拿一些这种轻的东西放在这个袋子里
Tasha: Take some of these lighter things and put them in this bag.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Katrina: 这蓝莓好大呀
Katrina: These blueberries are so big!
Jake: 车到了
Jake: The car is here.
Lucia: 要要不要再拿瓶饮料出来
Lucia: Do we need to take out another bottle of drink?
Lucia: 那个这个
Lucia: This one...
Lucia: 这个现在重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy now?
Alice: 这个不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Lucia: 我们要是还有别的那还得有别的袋子
Lucia: If we have more stuff, we'll need another bag.
Lucia: 那这个就放这吧
Lucia: Let's just put this here.
Katrina:  他没有布袋子吗
Katrina: Don't we have cloth bags?
Katrina:  只有这种袋子
Katrina: We only have these kinds of bags.
Tasha: 能不能租个推车回去
Tasha: Can we rent a cart to take it back?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 真的吗问问
Jake: Really? Let's ask.
Katrina: OK 啦这水不是的吧
Katrina: OK, this water isn't it, right?
Lucia: 这都是一些怕压的东西
Lucia: These are all things that can't be crushed.
Shure:  现在咱把他们放到最上面吧
Shure: Let's put them on top for now.
Lucia: 这个这个还行估计这个先放这里边
Lucia: This one is fine, let's put it here first.
Lucia: 像草莓鸡蛋这种这种
Lucia: Like strawberries, eggs, those kinds of things.
Alice: 这个可以放这个
Alice: This can go in here.
Alice:对这俩是一块
Alice: Yes, these two go together.
Alice:这是送的
Alice: This is a gift.
Tasha: 你摄像头呢
Tasha: Where is your camera?
Shure:  有吧
Shure: Should have it.
Jake: 呃换一个
Jake: Uh, switch to another one.
Jake: 这个没电了
Jake: This one is out of battery.
Jake: 这些先放车里吧
Jake: Let's put these in the car first.
Jake: 头掉了
Jake: The head fell off.
Jake: 哎呀来吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 来吧放这去
Katrina: Come on, put it here.
Alice:有点记不住
Alice: I can't really remember.
Katrina:  饮料要先放下边吧
Katrina: Should we put the drink down here first?
Katrina:  还是一会再放吧
Katrina: Or maybe later?
Katrina:  把饮料先垫下边
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's just do that.
Lucia: 我们还有袋子吗
Lucia: Do we still have a bag?
Lucia: 没有的话应该也能装下
Lucia: If not, it should still fit.
Lucia: 对要不把这个
Lucia: Yeah, or maybe this one?
Lucia: 我这底下已经放了一个饮料了
Lucia: I've already put a drink underneath here.
Katrina: 还有维c
Katrina: There's also vitamin C.
Lucia: 这个袋子是不是太重了
Lucia: Isn't this bag too heavy?
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: If so,
Katrina:  付钱喽
Katrina: Time to pay!
Shure:  付钱喽
Shure: Time to pay!
Jake: 送的呀
Jake: It's on the house.
Alice:付钱喽
Alice: Time to pay!
Tasha: 9块钱要买厨房湿巾吗
Tasha: Do you want to buy kitchen wipes for 9 yuan?
Shure:  来拿着
Shure: Here, take it.
Katrina:  来吧九块钱
Katrina: Come on, 9 yuan.
Tasha: 因为不是吃火锅吗
Tasha: Because aren't we having hotpot?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  拿着
Shure: Take it.
Tasha: 9块钱好像
Tasha: 9 yuan, I think.
Tasha: 啊9.9
Tasha: Oh, 9.9.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Tasha: 我真的还有这么多钱吗
Tasha: Do I really still have this much money?
Shure:  我相信你是个大富婆
Shure: I believe you're really rich.
Tasha: 你信错了
Tasha: You believed wrong.
Lucia: 这个这个能放到这吗
Lucia: Can we put this here?
Shure:  这个
Shure: This?
Katrina: 拿着我端着
Katrina: Hold on, I'll carry it.
Shure:  鸡蛋放这先
Shure: Put the eggs here first.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's do that first.
Lucia: 然后我们一会可以再看怎么样
Lucia: Then we can check again later.
Lucia: 整理一下好
Lucia: Let's organize it well.
Shure:  我天啊
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 这还有有包葱
Lucia: There's still a bag of scallions.
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmph
Tasha:这结了吗
Tasha: Is this done?
Lucia: 这是蒜
Lucia: This is garlic.
Alice: 这不是葱吗
Alice: Isn't this green onion?
Lucia: 这不是大蒜苗吗
Lucia: Isn't this garlic sprouts?
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Oh no.
Alice:一样的一样的
Alice: Same thing, same thing.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Shure:  谁不是谁把葱
Shure: Who mixed up the green onions?
Shure:  哎呀哈哈
Shure: Oh my, haha.
Lucia: 再买一个吧
Lucia: Just buy another one.
Tasha: 可以可以买
Tasha: Yes, we can buy it.
Lucia: 啊不是我觉得他是葱
Lucia: Ah, no, I think it's green onion.
Lucia: 他是葱同志们要不要看一眼
Lucia: It's green onion, guys, do you want to take a look?
Tasha: 蒜苗就是蒜苗
Tasha: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Shure:  蒜苗就是蒜苗
Shure: Garlic sprouts are garlic sprouts.
Tasha: 这这是蒜苗呀
Tasha: This is garlic sprouts.
Lucia: 这是蒜苗吗
Lucia: Is this garlic sprouts?
Alice:是是蒜苗
Alice: Yes, it's garlic sprouts.
Katrina: 这是一个叠被子
Katrina: This is a folded blanket.
Shure:  完全不是一个味
Shure: It's totally a different flavor.
Tasha: 才买个葱
Tasha: Just buy a green onion.
Katrina: 啊好的你来
Katrina: Ah, okay, you do it.
Alice: 无所谓把它当葱用吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, just use it as green onion.
Shure:  不行他俩完全不是一个味啊
Shure: No, they are totally different flavors.
Alice:也可以
Alice: It's fine too.
Tasha: 不是一个味啊
Tasha: It's not the same flavor.
Shure:  蒜苗是蒜的味
Shure: Garlic sprouts taste like garlic.
Lucia: 我刚才拿起来突然一看
Lucia: When I picked it up, I suddenly saw it.
Lucia: 这是到底是什么东西
Lucia: What on earth is this?
Shure:  那张那张账单在谁那呢
Shure: Who has the receipt?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: It's fine.
Katrina:  就两个呀
Katrina: Just two, right?
Shure:  还有一张账单啊
Shure: There's another receipt.
Katrina:  第一个没打是不是
Katrina: Didn't we print the first one?
Tasha: 第一个打了
Tasha: We did print the first one.
Tasha: 谁拿着呢
Tasha: Who's holding it?
Jake: 我我没拿呀
Jake: I don't have it.
Shure:  忘忘塞到哪了
Shure: Forgot where I put it.
Jake: 我可能没拿吧
Jake: I probably didn't take it.
Katrina: 贴脑门上
Katrina: Stick it on your forehead.
Tasha: 我没拿呀
Tasha: I didn't take it.
Jake: 我应该没拿
Jake: I don't think I took it.
Tasha: 我应该没拿呀
Tasha: I don't think I took it.
Jake: 那可能就是拿了吧
Jake: Then maybe you did take it.
Alice: 这不两条吗
Alice: Aren't there two strips here?
Tasha: 葱要不要再买一个
Tasha: Should we buy another green onion?
Jake: 两条吗我去
Jake: Two strips? Oh my.
Lucia: 哎那怎么又变成两条了
Lucia: Hey, how come it's two strips again?
Lucia: 还有一条
Lucia: There's one more.
Tasha:葱我去拿吧
Tasha: I'll go get the green onion.
Shure: 本来就两条
Shure: There were always two strips.
Jake: 应该连起来
Jake: They should be connected.
Lucia: 本来就两条
Lucia: There were always two strips.
Alice:哎哎哎去那边葱
Alice: Hey hey, go over there for the green onion.
Jake: 订一下
Jake: Order it.
Alice:有机葱比较贵
Alice: Organic green onions are more expensive.
Lucia: 小心这也是咱们的
Lucia: Be careful, this is ours too.
Lucia: 结过账的东西要看好
Lucia: Watch the items we've already paid for.
Jake: 去贴门禁
Jake: Go stick it on the access control.
Shure:  布袋是热啊
Shure: The bag is hot.
Katrina: 绝对不能让任何一个蛋受到伤害
Katrina: We absolutely can't let any egg get hurt.
Katrina: 封条
Katrina: Seal it.
Jake: 呃买二得三
Jake: Uh, buy two get three.
Katrina: 你在英国呆有没有人就是抢
Katrina: When you were in the UK, did anyone ever snatch anything?
Katrina: 你有遭遇过抢劫吗
Katrina: Have you ever been robbed?
Lucia: 嗯我倒是没碰到过
Lucia: Hmm, I haven't encountered that.
Lucia: 不过这种事确实挺多的
Lucia: But it does happen quite a lot.
Katrina: 就是逛超市这种可能会抢吗
Katrina: Like in a supermarket, is it possible to get robbed?
Jake: 总共就两条吧
Jake: There are only two strips, right?
Lucia: 哦好像有这种事吧但我没有
Lucia: Oh, I think such things happen, but not to me.
Lucia: 但我没有目睹过
Lucia: But I haven't witnessed it.
Lucia: 据说有我们可以讨论这个吗
Lucia: They say so, can we discuss this?
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure, sure.
Lucia: 涉嫌什么谈论
Lucia: What are we discussing?
Lucia: 谈论那个
Lucia: Discussing that.
Lucia: 哈哈哈说一些不好的话
Lucia: Hahaha, saying some bad things.
Jake: 没关系就这个翻译给他乱翻译一个
Jake: It's okay, just let the translator mess it up.
Jake: American is the best
Jake: American is the best.
Alice:结一下吧
Alice: Let's settle it.
Alice:结吧结吧
Alice: Let's settle it, let's settle it.
Lucia: 会翻译成这样吗
Lucia: Will it be translated like this?
Alice: 这怎么拿回去啊
Alice: How do we take this back?
Katrina:  一人一个
Katrina: One for each person.
Jake: 翻译翻过去就是美国的东西很便宜
Jake: The translation says American stuff is really cheap.
Jake: 大家喜欢买便宜的东西
Jake: Everyone likes to buy cheap stuff.
Lucia: 大家喜欢花最低的价格买东西
Lucia: Everyone likes to buy things at the lowest price.
Katrina: 真正开元的是老乡鸡 你的仓库star还没有老乡鸡多
Katrina: The true start was Lao Xiang Ji. Your warehouse still doesn't have as much as Lao Xiang Ji.
Jake: 让眼镜记一下
Jake: Let the glasses note it.
Shure:  给大家报个菜名吧
Shure: Tell everyone the dish names.
Shure:  眼镜嗯
Shure: Glasses, hmm.
Shure:  对对屏看看你的
Shure: Yes, yes, look at your screen.
Katrina:  看我小红书
Katrina: Look at my Xiaohongshu.
Shure:  看小红书都有什么
Shure: See what's on Xiaohongshu.
Tasha: 给老板
Tasha: For the boss.
Alice: 给老板
Alice: For the boss.
Katrina:  啊这很有品啊
Katrina: Ah, this is very stylish.
Katrina:  这说明我
Katrina: This shows that I...
Shure:  原来你也喜欢这一口
Shure: So you like this stuff too.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Tasha: 我帮你贴上吗
Tasha: Should I stick it for you?
Jake: 好啊哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, hahaha.
Jake: 你就你就
Jake: Just, just...
Jake: 你就欠这一刀
Jake: You just need this cut.
Jake: 手带现在这个长度很好
Jake: The length of the wristband is good now.
Jake: 就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  go
Shure: Go.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my God.
Tasha: 那芋头还有蛋挞皮
Tasha: There's taro and egg tart crusts.
Tasha: 还有刚刚说的薄荷
Tasha: And also the mint we just mentioned.
Jake: 这车能推到哪啊
Jake: Where can this cart be pushed to?
Katrina: 薄荷
Katrina: Mint.
Tasha: 还有你们那个好像还有两个材料
Tasha: And you guys still have two ingredients.
Shure: 门口
Shure: The entrance.
Jake: 门口
Jake: The entrance.
Jake: 哪个门口外边
Jake: Which entrance, outside.
Tasha: 就从网上买的
Tasha: I just bought it online.
Alice:美纹纸
Katrina:  嗯那偏文具类的我上网买
Katrina: Yeah, for stationery stuff, I buy online.
Katrina:  或者是我看看外送有没有
Katrina: Or I check if there's delivery.
Katrina: 因为我们在设计地球的
Katrina: Because we're designing for Earth.
Katrina:  啊什么东西上网买
Katrina: Oh, what stuff do you buy online?
Katrina: 感觉会漂亮一点
Katrina: It tends to look nicer.
Tasha: 肯定也会在网上买的吧
Tasha: You'd probably buy it online too, right?
Tasha: 我觉得啊
Tasha: I think so.
Tasha: 海报什么东西
Tasha: Posters and stuff.
Shure:  你好这车最远能推到哪啊
Shure: Hey, how far can you push this cart?
Shure:  就到这就到头了
Shure: Is this the furthest it can go?
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Tasha: 车不能推到商场门口吗
Tasha: Can't we push the cart to the mall entrance?
Alice:我的天呐啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake: 能租车
Jake: We can rent a cart.
Lucia: 这叫我们怎么拿出去啊
Lucia: How are we supposed to carry all this out?
Shure:  杨老板先把车打上吧
Shure: Jake, start the car first.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们就直接打车了
Jake: Let's just call a cab.
Jake: 不再买点咖啡什么的
Jake: Aren't we getting some coffee or something?
Jake: 不了吧
Jake: Nah.
Jake: 现在有点晚了
Jake: It's kinda late now.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 不用喝了
Tasha: No need for coffee.
Katrina:  我们直接去吃饭是吗
Katrina: Are we going straight to eat?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 对吃什么呢
Tasha: Yeah, what are we eating?
Shure:  你们拎着这么多东西
Shure: You guys are carrying so much stuff.
Alice: 这地能有放的吗
Alice: Is there a place to put these things?
Shure:  东西
Shure: Stuff.
Jake: 确实啊
Jake: True.
Shure: 肯定得回趟家
Shure: We definitely need to go home first.
Lucia: 拿这么多东西去吃饭有点
Lucia: It's a bit much to carry all this stuff to dinner.
Tasha: 要不就点外卖吧
Tasha: How about we just order delivery?
Jake: 行回去点外卖吧
Jake: Okay, let's go home and order delivery.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 都可以一起出去也可以
Lucia: We can all go out together too.
Jake: 在这是就是有冻的东西对吧
Jake: There's frozen stuff here, right?
Shure:  是吧而且还有要要冻的东西
Shure: Right, and there are frozen items as well.
Jake: 是吧是有冷冻的
Jake: Yeah, there are frozen ones.
Jake: 冷冻的东西
Jake: Frozen items.
Shure:  然后大家看一眼那个哪些是冷冻
Shure: So everyone should check which ones are frozen.
Shure:  哪些是冷藏
Shure: And which ones are refrigerated.
Katrina:  放一会吧
Katrina: Let's leave it for a bit.
Shure:  比如说那毛肚什么的
Shure: For example, the beef tripe.
Shure:  他就是说让0-4度
Shure: It needs to be kept at 0-4 degrees.
Tasha: 你要放下来吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it down?
Jake: 啊再来一辆车你要不
Jake: Ah, do you want another cart?
Shure:  他只能到这儿了
Shure: This is as far as it can go.
Tasha: 他只能到这儿了
Tasha: This is as far as it can go.
Shure:  爸爸只能送你到这儿了
Shure: Dad can only take you this far.
Shure:  未来的路要靠你自己了
Shure: The rest of the journey, you have to do on your own.
Lucia: 妈耶
Lucia: Oh my.
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure:  那是你的朗姆的声音
Shure: That's the sound of your rum.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Shure:  他现在向你发出回应
Shure: It's responding to you now.
Katrina:  这样我们的冰箱就满了
Katrina: Our fridge is full now.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 冰箱能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can the fridge hold it?
Shure:  你不要把它喝凉了
Shure: Don't let it get too cold.
Katrina:  哈哈哈全喝光
Katrina: Haha, drink it all.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Later.
Katrina: 草莓也全吃了
Katrina: Also eat all the strawberries.
Jake: 就是这个数据比较重要
Jake: This data is quite important.
Jake: 就是回头你们收拾的时候
Jake: When you guys clean up later,
Jake: 会和超市
Jake: You'll have some connection with the supermarket.
Jake: 你们的一些行为建立一些联系
Jake: Your actions will establish some links.
Jake: 就是比方说你把这东西放到冰箱
Jake: For example, when you put this item in the fridge,
Jake: 然后他只能找回到你在哪找到的那个
Jake: It can trace back to where you found it.
Lucia: 哦那就跟亚马逊那个无人采购超市
Lucia: Oh, like the Amazon unmanned grocery store.
Lucia: 一样的那种感觉
Lucia: That kind of feeling.
Jake: 对对对溯源
Jake: Yes, traceability.
Katrina: 溯源啦
Katrina: Traceability.
Jake: 对就是溯源这种rechieve
Jake: Yes, traceability, this kind of retrieve.
Jake: 特厉害你去不
Jake: It's amazing, right?
Shure:  你们上链的吗
Shure: Are you guys blockchain?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  当心哦
Katrina: Be careful.
Lucia: 阿莫总开了好几个那种
Lucia: Amour has opened several of those...
Lucia: 那种超市
Lucia: ...those supermarkets.
Lucia: 就是你出门不用结账
Lucia: The kind where you don't need to check out.
Lucia: 他知道你买了什么
Lucia: It knows what you bought.
Lucia: 然后自动在你的账户里付款
Lucia: And then it automatically charges your account.
Lucia: 就是他根据你的重量
Lucia: It goes by the weight.
Lucia: 好像就是你放进去然后东西多重
Lucia: Like, you put it in and it knows the weight.
Lucia: 对他会精确到多少多少毫克
Lucia: Yeah, it can be precise to the milligram.
Lucia: 然后呢他就会自动把这钱扣走
Lucia: Then it automatically deducts the money.
Lucia: 是超市里
Lucia: In the supermarket.
Lucia: 就跟我们一样
Lucia: Just like us.
Jake:那我要稍微哎
Jake: Well, I need to...
Lucia: 就是它有很多摄像头
Lucia: It has a lot of cameras.
Lucia: 就是能看到你拿了什么
Lucia: They can see what you take.
Lucia: 他监测你有没有在货架上拿东西
Lucia: They monitor if you take anything from the shelves.
Lucia: 包括你进出的时候的各种数据
Lucia: Including various data when you enter and leave.
Lucia: 反正很神奇的一个东西
Lucia: It's a really amazing thing.
Lucia: 不过就是偶尔有算错的可能性
Lucia: But sometimes it might make mistakes.
Shure:  那肯定
Shure: For sure.
Shure:  因为每一个我都这么拿
Shure: Because I pick up every single item like this.
Lucia: 哎那个好像他也能监测的到
Lucia: Well, it seems like it can detect that too.
Lucia: 呵呵不过有时候是会算错的
Lucia: Hehe, but sometimes it does make mistakes.
Shure:  我打个雨伞呐
Shure: If I hold an umbrella...
Shure:  他肯定检测不到了吧
Shure: It definitely can't detect that, right?
Lucia: 去实验一下
Lucia: Go test it out.
Jake: 就是这是他的玻璃
Jake: This is its glass.
Jake:玻璃好歹还在人抢
Jake: At least the glass is still there for people to steal.
Jake: 好歹还算算法错误
Jake: At least it's an algorithm error.
Shure:  就是我就爱打伞
Shure: I just love holding an umbrella.
Shure:  在室内
Shure: Indoors.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Isn't it?
Jake: 他有可能是商品上面贴条了
Jake: Maybe they put tags on the items.
Jake: 贴无线电
Jake: RFID tags.
Jake: 他还有6分钟到
Jake: He'll be here in 6 minutes.
Alice:开始往下走吧
Alice: Let's start heading down.
Jake: 往上走好像是
Jake: Seems like we should go up.
Jake:这是往上走对吧
Jake: We're going up, right?
Katrina:  往下吧这不是二楼吗
Katrina: We're going down, isn't this the second floor?
Alice:我们不是二楼吗
Alice: Aren't we on the second floor?
Alice:我们是这样上来的呀
Alice: We came up this way.
Jake:哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, that's how it is.
Alice: 一进门一进门不是有个升的电梯
Alice: As soon as you enter, there's an elevator that goes up.
Jake: 有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 因为这地方太像地下了
Jake: This place feels like a basement.
Alice: 有点阴森有点不热闹
Alice: It's a bit creepy and not lively.
Shure:  我在搞地下音乐
Shure: I'm into underground music.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:有点
Alice: A bit.
Katrina:  这我来吧
Katrina: Let me handle this.
Katrina: 因为我有一个鸡蛋
Katrina: Because I have an egg.
Alice: 没事这个不沉
Alice: It's okay, this isn't heavy.
Katrina:  你看
Katrina: Look.
Katrina:  没事我就一点点都没
Katrina: It's fine, I barely have anything.
Tasha: 你你一个人拎两个
Tasha: You're carrying two by yourself?
Katrina: 就主要是那个酒比较多的那个
Katrina: Mainly the one with more alcohol.
Jake: 你你你这么厉害吗
Jake: You're really that strong?
Alice: 而且饮料多的比较沉
Alice: And the one with more drinks is heavier.
Alice: 你再一人掂一掂
Alice: You should each carry one.
Jake: 这才对嘛
Jake: That's more like it.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  您是
Shure: You are...
Katrina: 没事你你
Katrina: It's okay, you...
Katrina: 真的可以这样利用老板吗
Katrina: Can we really use the boss like this?
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:这样比较平衡
Jake: This way is more balanced.
Shure:  这样比较这厨房湿巾一定很沉吧
Shure: This kitchen towel must be really heavy.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这这鸡蛋也很沉吧
Tasha: Haha, this egg is really heavy too, right?
Lucia: 哈哈这鸡蛋很宝贵
Lucia: Haha, this egg is precious.
Shure:  对没事
Shure: It's fine.
Katrina:  我需要专人护送
Katrina: I need special escort.
Shure:  我只送到你们到门口
Shure: I'll just escort you to the door.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我这线是掉了吗
Jake: Did my wire fall off?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss.
Tasha: 老板拎着最多的东西
Tasha: The boss is carrying the most stuff.
Lucia: 真的真的
Lucia: Really, really.
Lucia: 要不要帮你安上
Lucia: Do you want me to help you set it up?
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia: 你别走
Lucia: Don't move.
Jake: OK了开始开动
Jake: Okay, let's get started.
Katrina: connected
Katrina: Connected.
Shure:  这是老板吗
Shure: Is this the boss?
Shure:  我们是被一个AI领导的一群人类
Shure: We're being led by an AI. 社会问题
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 呃重吗我跟你一起拎
Tasha: Is it heavy? I'll help you carry it.
Alice:不用不用这个就一个兜啊
Alice: No, no, it's just one bag.
Jake: 就我我头上的和我眼前的
Jake: Just the one on my head and the one in front of me.
Shure: 那个鸡蛋保护起来一定很累
Shure: Protecting that egg must be exhausting.
Jake: 就是我的接收设备
Jake: It's my receiving device.
Jake: 我全靠他来支撑我
Jake: I rely on it entirely.
Katrina: 不行你没有这个资格
Katrina: No, you don't have the qualification.
Jake: 哈哈哈一些行为
Jake: Hahaha, some actions.
Lucia: 这个故事开始向恐怖片方向发展了
Lucia: This story is starting to turn into a horror movie.
Shure:  但
Shure: But...
Katrina:  蛋蛋
Katrina: Egg, egg.
Katrina:  蛋
Katrina: Egg.
Tasha: 这颗葱拐到你的脚了
Tasha: This scallion got twisted around your foot.
Tasha: 我帮你拿着
Tasha: Let me hold it for you.
Shure:  你要把鼻也夹进去
Shure: You need to clip your nose in too.
Jake:啊会吗谢谢
Jake: Oh, really? Thanks.
Katrina: 所以他们要
Katrina: So they need to...
Jake: 所以很重要
Jake: So it's important.
Katrina: 所以你们最后买葱了吗
Katrina: So did you guys end up buying the scallion?
Jake: 哈哈哈所以呢
Jake: Hahaha, so what?
Jake:哈哈哈critical
Jake: Hahaha, critical.
Alice:买了买了
Alice: Yes, we bought it.
Shure:  买了这么大一节葱白
Shure: We bought this huge scallion.
Alice:不是这还是蒜苗
Alice: No, it's still garlic shoots.
Alice:我们的葱在那个篮里面呢
Alice: Our scallion is in that basket.
Tasha: 买了一个葱姜蒜组合
Tasha: We bought a scallion, ginger, and garlic combo.
Shure:  发明这个的人真是天才
Shure: The person who invented this is a genius.
Jake: 我觉得每人带根线是有点酷啊
Jake: I think everyone carrying a wire is kind of cool.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:你这么一眼看过去
Jake: At a glance
Alice:尤其我们这样走在一起
Alice: Especially when we're walking together
Shure: 一会我回程的路上要地铁
Shure: I need to take the subway on my way back
Alice:感觉像一个什么组织
Alice: Feels like some kind of organization
Tasha: 有点像一个神秘组织
Tasha: Kind of like a secret organization
Shure: 这个数据要录下来吗
Shure: Should we record this data?
Jake: 可以录
Jake: Yes, we can record it
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Tasha: 尤其这个眼镜还发光的感觉
Tasha: Especially with these glowing glasses
Katrina: 但他地铁要差不多两个小时
Katrina: But his subway ride takes almost two hours
Jake:你地铁你地铁
Jake: Your subway, your subway
Tasha: 大家都带同一款
Tasha: Everyone's wearing the same style
Jake: 进个进一下出一下得了
Jake: Just go in and out
Jake: 你就进去吧
Jake: Just go in
Jake: 进去然后就关掉
Jake: Go in and then turn it off
Jake: 然后主要是你看你答辩
Jake: The main thing is to see your defense
Jake:哈哈哈你答辩
Jake: Haha, your defense
Shure:  真的真的好录吗
Shure: Really, is it okay to record?
Shure:  方便吗方便哎
Shure: Is it convenient?
Jake:方便
Jake: Convenient
Jake: 你问Andy对吧你的老师Andy
Jake: Ask Andy, right? Your teacher Andy
Shure:  说我在进行一个奇怪的项目
Shure: Say that I'm working on a strange project
Jake: 对你问Andy想不想进数据集
Jake: Yes, ask Andy if he wants to be in the dataset
Jake: 想不想被人研究研究
Jake: Does he want to be studied?
Shure:  安妮好像英国人会对这
Shure: Annie, being British, might be
Shure:  隐私方面更敏感一些吧
Shure: More sensitive about privacy, right?
Lucia: 我们往哪走啊
Lucia: Where are we going?
Lucia: 是这边吗
Lucia: This way?
Alice: 都可以出去
Alice: We can go out either way
Tasha: 这边是我们刚刚
Tasha: This way is where we just came from
Tasha: 最近的那个
Tasha: The nearest one
Katrina: 你们这剪头发128呢
Katrina: You guys paid 128 for a haircut?
Jake: 这是探路去了
Jake: That's just exploring
Katrina:  这是北京的物价吗
Katrina: Is that Beijing's price?
Shure:  呃也不至于
Shure: Uh, not really
Katrina:  我觉得也是吧
Katrina: I think so too
Katrina:  这个应该也能出去吧
Katrina: This should be the way out too, right?
Shure:  四五十是不是
Shure: About fifty, right?
Lucia: 我们为什么不从那里出呢
Lucia: Why don't we go out that way?
Katrina: 那才比较正常
Katrina: That sounds more reasonable
Jake: 帮我接个电话
Jake: Help me answer the phone.
Katrina: 你放地上吧
Katrina: Just put it on the ground.
Jake: 算了我来
Jake: Never mind, I'll do it.
Shure:  要不我送你们到这我就先溜了
Shure: How about I drop you guys off here and then I'll head off?
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 拜拜明天见
Katrina: Bye-bye, see you tomorrow.
Shure:  走吧再见
Shure: Let's go, goodbye.
Jake: 哎我想挠头我靠
Jake: Ah, I want to scratch my head, damn it.
Jake: 拜拜明天见
Jake: Bye-bye, see you tomorrow.
Shure:  明天见今晚不要想我哦
Shure: See you tomorrow, don't miss me tonight.
Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello, hi.
Katrina: 希望你答辩顺利哦
Katrina: Hope your defense goes well.
Tasha: 对你就到这了
Tasha: Yeah, you stop here.
Shure:  对我就到这了
Shure: Yeah, I stop here.
Shure:  呃所以你不能只拎一包湿巾
Shure: Uh, so you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Jake: 呃呃我找找你吧
Jake: Uh, uh, I'll come find you.
Jake: 我按照定位找你吧
Jake: I'll find you based on the location.
Jake: 你到了对吧
Jake: You've arrived, right?
Shure:  所以你不能只拎一包湿巾了
Shure: So you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Shure:  拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎哎拜拜拜拜
Jake: Hey, bye-bye bye-bye.
Jake: 无语哈哈哈
Jake: Speechless, hahaha.
Alice: 我们这能放下吗
Alice: Can we put this down here?
Lucia: 同想问
Lucia: Same question.
Alice:可以吧
Alice: Should be fine, right?
Katrina: 放后备箱
Katrina: Put it in the trunk.
Jake: 好像说在那个地方
Jake: It seems to be at that place.
Jake: 你看你看是在
Jake: Look, look, it's there.
Alice: 嗯是这个门出去
Alice: Hmm, it's out this door.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 我们刚刚下车的地
Alice: The place where we just got off.
Katrina:  我们俩一起
Katrina: The two of us together.
Jake: 那你帮我导个航
Jake: Then help me with the navigation.
Jake: 好谢谢你
Jake: Okay, thank you.
Katrina:  哎我好害怕这人
Katrina: Oh, I'm so scared of this person.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 哎呦
Jake: Oh dear.
Katrina:  哇这一包这么重他刚刚拎的
Katrina: Wow, this bag is so heavy, he just carried it.
Lucia: 没有那袋重
Lucia: That bag isn't heavy.
Tasha: 我说真的
Tasha: I'm serious.
Katrina:  因为我买了两大瓶哎
Katrina: Because I bought two big bottles.
Jake: 这个很重要这个很重要这个
Jake: This is very important, this is very important.
Jake: 这个哎可以谢谢谢谢
Jake: This is good, thank you, thank you.
Alice:好了不用走了就在这
Alice: Alright, no need to go, just stay here.
Katrina:  他能进来吗
Katrina: Can he come in?
Jake: 他能进来啊
Jake: He can come in.
Jake: 这么厉害
Jake: So amazing.
Lucia: 我就把这个放下了啊
Lucia: I'll just put this down.
Jake: 今天挺暖和的
Jake: It's quite warm today.
Jake: 一点也不冷
Jake: Not cold at all.
Katrina:  新加坡一般多少度啊
Katrina: What's the usual temperature in Singapore?
Jake: 呃 23-31每天
Jake: Uh, 23-31 degrees every day.
Katrina:  基本上四季都是吗
Katrina: Is it like this all year round?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day is the same.
Tasha: 这么热嗯
Tasha: So hot, huh?
Jake: 每天都一样
Jake: Every day is the same.
Jake: 是挺闷的
Jake: It's quite humid.
Jake: 但是现在我适应了
Jake: But now I'm used to it.
Jake: 我觉得还好
Jake: I think it's okay.
Jake: 只要中午不出去都还好
Jake: As long as you don't go out at noon, it's fine.
Tasha: 哇你看这个大葱头
Tasha: Wow, look at this big green onion.
Lucia: 你们是四季如夏吗
Lucia: Do you have summer all year round?
Tasha: 上下两层都是这样子的
Tasha: Both upper and lower layers are like this.
Jake: 对是不是每天都一样
Jake: Yes, isn't it the same every day?
Alice:我是不是得
Alice: Do I need to...
Jake: 赤道2度北纬2度
Jake: 2 degrees north of the equator.
Lucia: 真的好热
Lucia: It's really hot.
Lucia: 你知不知道
Lucia: Do you know?
Alice:往那再走一点点
Alice: Move a little bit further there.
Katrina: 路边是不是应该进不来吧
Katrina: The roadside should not be accessible, right?
Tasha: 他不能进来吗
Tasha: Can't he come in?
Alice:不知道能不能过去
Alice: I don't know if he can get through.
Tasha: 让他打电话问他一下吧
Tasha: Let him call and ask.
Jake: 我这个电话我这欠费了
Jake: My phone is out of credit.
Jake: 打不出去
Jake: I can't make calls.
Tasha: 让他进来了调个头
Tasha: Let him come in and turn around.
Jake: 他是什么色的
Jake: What color is he driving?
Alice:他好像停了
Alice: He seems to have stopped.
Alice:别克GL8
Alice: It's a Buick GL8.
Jake: 他是要我们走过去吧
Jake: He's asking us to walk over there, right?
Alice:我们应该往前走一点点吧
Alice: We should move forward a bit, right?
Jake: 那我们走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake: 走哎
Jake: Let's move.
Jake: 我刚刚拿的是这个吗
Jake: Was this what I just took?
Jake: 这是地铁吗
Jake: Is this the subway?
Alice: 喂您好
Alice: Hello, hi.
Jake: 最前面这一条
Jake: The very first one.
Jake: 天上这一条
Jake: The one up there.
Lucia: 是的那呃
Lucia: Yes, um...
Alice:呃暂时还没有
Alice: Uh, not yet.
Jake: 1号线哎
Jake: It's Line 1.
Jake: 是1号线吗
Jake: Is it Line 1?
Jake: 几号线
Jake: Which line is it?
Katrina: 咱走这出去吧
Katrina: Let's exit this way.
Alice:永和大王
Alice: Yonghe King.
Jake: 奔驰啊是吗呵呵呵
Jake: A Mercedes, huh? Haha.
Jake: 是吧哈哈
Jake: Right? Haha.
Alice: 永和大王门口
Alice: In front of Yonghe King.
Lucia: 永和大王那边
Lucia: Over by Yonghe King.
Tasha: 门口
Tasha: The entrance.
Alice:是是那个吗
Alice: Is it that one?
Alice: 我靠哎呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:双闪的
Alice: The one with the hazards on.
Katrina: 啥颜色
Katrina: What color is it?
Alice:看到有双闪
Alice: I see the hazards.
Lucia: 哪有哪有
Lucia: Where, where?
Alice: 咋是不是那个呀
Alice: Is it that one?
Jake: 啊我看到了
Jake: Ah, I see it.
Jake: 对对对确实
Jake: Yeah, for sure.
Alice:我是不是得绕一下
Alice: Should I go around?
Jake: 呃就那边吧
Jake: Just over there.
Jake: 不用绕
Jake: No need to go around.
Alice: 那个那个我们这能出去吧
Alice: Can we exit from here?
Katrina: 我们去
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure:  啊我现在
Shure: Ah, now I...
Tasha: 我先过
Tasha: I'll go first.
Alice:呃好的
Alice: Uh, okay.
Alice:好的我们找到了谢谢
Alice: Okay, we found it. Thanks.
Lucia: 这个我们是不是可以放后备箱
Lucia: Can we put this in the trunk?
Jake: fa
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Katrina: 开后备箱
Katrina: Open the trunk.
Alice: 后备箱可以打开吗
Alice: Can the trunk be opened?
Tasha: 啊天呐咦
Tasha: Oh my god, ew.
Alice:有点小
Alice: It's a bit small.
Katrina: 够还是够
Katrina: It's still enough.
Alice:挤一下吧
Alice: Let's squeeze it in.
Alice:再来一个
Alice: Add one more.
Katrina:  鸡蛋我抱着吧
Katrina: I'll hold the eggs.
Katrina:  这不还和鸡蛋放哪了
Katrina: Where should I put these eggs?
Jake: 谢谢哎呀哎呦
Jake: Thank you, ouch, ouch.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Katrina:  哎呦哎呦
Katrina: Ouch, ouch.
Katrina:  疼
Katrina: It hurts.
Jake: 好疼
Jake: It really hurts.
Alice:还空出来一个位
Alice: There's still a spot left.
Alice:要不然搁前边吧
Alice: Or put it in the front.
Katrina:  放放我身上也行
Katrina: Putting it on me is fine too.
Katrina:  这后面只有两个人
Katrina: Only two people in the back.
Jake: 就放那边吧
Jake: Just put it over there.
Jake: 放那边可以吧
Jake: Is it okay to put it there?
Katrina: 少了个人
Katrina: Someone's missing.
Jake: 还是放哎呦
Jake: Still put it, ouch.
Jake: 看一眼
Jake: Take a look.
Jake: 好疼好疼啊
Jake: It really hurts, really hurts.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No way.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵摸摸头
Jake: Haha, pat my head.
Shure:  OK好OK
Shure: OK, alright, OK.
Jake: 摸摸头
Jake: Pat my head.
Jake: 哎不用不用不用
Jake: No need, no need, no need.
Jake: 它自动的它自动的它自动的自动的
Jake: It's automatic, it's automatic, it's automatic.
Alice:好的给你的
Alice: Okay, here you go.
Jake: 摁了他就以为我们要干什么
Jake: If we press it, he might think we're up to something.
Alice:我们俩坐后边吧
Alice: The two of us will sit in the back.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Tasha: 啊怎么还订6座呢
Tasha: Why did we book a 6-seater?
Jake: 那应该点几座
Jake: How many should we have booked?
Katrina:  那我坐老板位了
Katrina: I'll take the boss's seat.
Lucia: 那我还坐前面吧
Lucia: Then I'll sit in the front.
Lucia: 如果没有人晕车的话
Lucia: If no one gets car sick
Alice:来吧baby
Alice: Come on, baby
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Tasha: 好疼
Tasha: Ouch, that hurts
Lucia: 哎这个能往后一点吗
Lucia: Hey, can this move back a bit?
Lucia: 啊不我是说这个
Lucia: Ah no, I mean this
Alice:现在还要录吗
Alice: Do we still need to record?
Jake: 这个关了吧
Jake: 不用录了
Jake: No need to record anymore
Tasha: 呃现在就关了
Tasha: Uh, turn it off now?
Jake: 现在关了
Jake: Turn it off now
Jake: 可以这一段
Jake: This part is fine
Jake: 这一段主要没有go Pro
Jake: This part mainly doesn't have the GoPro
Jake: 你每次go Pro贼麻烦
Jake: Every time the GoPro is so troublesome
Alice:又把我家地址录上去
Alice: Again, you recorded my home address
Katrina:  终止是吗
Katrina: Stop, right?
Katrina:  行
Katrina: Okay